so you know how all of us in our lives
as we're living you're running a
business you have a family of kids you
have different responsibilities and we
noticed that something is not doing well
some area of our life is not doing well
why is it that some part of our life
isn't doing well and I was having this
conversation with somebody earlier where
someone had completely lost momentum
with their business and they're trying
to find out why that happened because
when they were very excited about their
business they were doing very well they
were on top of the world and then all of
a sudden one day they're thinking how
come my businesses and do well and in
what I told the person I was speaking to
I said look in my life I've lost great
relationships I've lost
money lots of money I've lost I have
lost momentum and business early 20s I
have lost a lot of those things and the
simplest way I process it is everything
in life needs attention and if you don't
give it attention you lose it everything
requires attention let me simplify it
for you if you're having momentum in
your marriage and all of a sudden you
think that momentum is going to carry
your marriage permanently forever and
you start giving it attention you're
going to lose momentum in your marriage
if you say I've been using Proactiv and
my skin is feeling much better now I
love the way my skin looks and you don't
give your skin any more attention you're
going to have bad skin again if you say
I've lost 17 pounds I feel like I like
the way I look right now my body looks
very good I feel good and you stop
giving attention to the diet and your
exercise routine you're going to gain
weight again if you don't pay attention
to your business you have a lot of
momentum and you're doing well you have
your best income and your best grossing
revenue net revenue growth
percentage-wise you're excited
everything's looking good if you don't
give your business the proper attention
it needs you're going to lose the
success you're having in your business
because everything in life needs
attention
everything in life needs attention if
your finances at one point was doing
very good and now it's not it's because
it's not getting enough attention so
life is all about giving attention to
things that matter and if you don't give
it attention
don't be surprised when the results that
you once used to get you're not getting
in in all aspects of your of your life
and giving attention is not about hey my
relation my kid is not doing good so
we're going to sit down and watch a you
know constantly TV together and we're
going to switch to each other that's not
real intentional attention intentional
attention is I'm going to take my kid to
the park and
go to dinner and we're going to have a
conversation together for one hour I'm
going to take my wife out to dinner and
we're going to have a date night and
we're going to talk about our marriage
for one hour and have her tell me what
things she's frustrated with that's
intentional attention I'm going to go to
the gym and I'm not just going to fool
around at the gym for one hour because I
have a limited time I have big plans my
life I'm going to take my time and I
want to talk to people so I'm going to
have a earpiece in my ear even if my
phone ran out of batteries or my ipod
ran out of batteries I want this to make
you think not talk to me because I want
to exercise because I'm intentional
about taking care of my body giving it
attention be more intentional about the
attention that you've given to different
aspects of your life that are important
to you and you will not lose momentum
but if you take your attention off be
prepared to lose momentum in that part
of your life so it's my challenge to you
go out there and give attention to those
things anyways that's my message of the
week to you and feel free to comment on
the bottom and subscribe to the channel
thanks for watching
you